hi there Steve coffin here today to talk
about language learning and multitasking
now remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe give me a like if you
want but the reason I want to talk about
multitasking is because multitasking is
a big part of my language learning if I
if I look at where I spend my time
learning languages basically it's
listening while doing something else or
you know sitting down with the iPad and
reading and saving words and phrases on
link those are the two activities I also
have some books all occasionally
referred to I was looking at my Persian
book this morning looking through the
glossary at the back sometimes it's good
to review these words but multitasking
is a big part right in fact yesterday
and I like to do something with either
Persian or Arabic every day and I also
like to work out everyday I like to go
to the gym there's a gym here in our
community and last night it was raining
and the way there wasn't very good and I
didn't feel like going to the gym I
didn't didn't feel like studying Persian
kind of burnout double burnout and but
then I said to myself if I go to the gym
I can listen to person so something
about that the fact that that I would
not only be working out but also
listening to Persian or I wouldn't just
be listening to Persian I would also be
working out that was sufficient
motivation that I went down to the gym
worked out and listened to Persian and
you know a lot of my language learning
time is listening while cleaning up
while doing other tasks the bulk of my
language learning time is listening and
that is only I only listen while doing
something else and so I thought about
this like if I sit there and listen I
will very soon get distracted I won't be
able to continue so there's something
about the fact and I've noticed too that
one of the my best sort of language
learning situations is being on an
aeroplane particularly you know 3 4 5 6
7 hours because
stuck there so that there's less
opportunity to say to yourself gee I
should be doing something else I should
get up and do this or you're there
you're stuck so you remove the
distraction and and to some extent it's
the same when I'm multitasking if I'm
cleaning up you know doing the dishes or
whatever I mean I have to do that so
while doing that I am listening and then
I don't mind doing the chore so I don't
know why this is and I'd be interested
in reactions from other people like if
I'm sitting in the doctor's office
waiting to see the doctor that's a very
good time to study I sit there in fact
there I don't listen there I'll sit and
read through stuff on my iPad so that
being for being in a situation where you
are not distracted or where you are the
sort of temptation for distraction is
taken up by some other activity might be
an activity like you know working out or
like you know even on Kate we have a
quiet vacuum cleaner I can listen while
vacuuming about dusting while doing the
dishes and so I don't have to I don't
have to be totally a hundred percent
focused while listening but inevitably
when I listen I notice new things that I
haven't noticed before and so if it's
you know an hour and a half while
multitasking and let's say I lose focus
ten twenty percent of the time or even
more I don't know but the other time I
am focused I am picking things up I am
reinforcing things I am noticing things
so it's actually very good you know a
good way to learn while multitasking and
I find that I am better able to
concentrate that way now obviously if I
am reading I have to sit there and focus
and that's why when I have dedicated
study time I read I read and save words
and phrases but that's a small
percentage of the time the bulk of the
time is listening and listening is so
super powerful like me you know you got
your little air pod this guy is a
smaller
version of my it's not the iPhone
because it's a lot lighter the iPod and
I take it with me and it's just so
convenient and these are things that
were not available fifty years ago I
mean you can have accessing podcasts and
getting the transcripts and I have you
know on this little thing I have a
library of material that wasn't
available to people learning languages
50 years ago I can access my podcast
from there it's amazing but the core to
my ability to spend so much time
language learning is the ability to
multitask and I would be very interested
to hear whether other people have a
similar experience or a similar approach
so thank you for listening by the way
remember if you want my 10 lessons on
how to learn languages you can click
here and subscribe to this email of
course alright then thank you
[Music]